[Music]
the biggest complaint from new yorkers
complaining the three one one go three
one one there's a rat is that their four
one one
what's three one calzone three ones like
i have a complaint about something going
on oh it's a suggestion box for the city
oh like karate rat kung fu kung fu new
york rat so i want to tell on people but
there's not much there's a stinky sewer
around here yeah the cops are gonna hang
up so like there's all this trash in the
street there's a bum in my apartment
again why is the bar was closed yeah i
was totally safe
so that's what it was so sorrows is a
new york institution
no it's not that dammit
noise complaints what kind of what kind
of noise sex sex that's what it is
so loud sex is the biggest complaint
from new yorkers complaining to three
one one so the city that never sleeps am
i right
hey give me five right now please thank
you i demand it
all right so new york city's
non-emergency hotline has been inundated
with complaints that from callers who
are not fans of quote loud sex
more than 270 sex related complaints
were called into 3-1-1 with reports of
everything from backyard orgies
massive sex parties
sounds of loud quote ruth laughing sex
that kind of stuff sex that's happening
ruthlessly
in the middle of the afternoon and what
one person described as grunts from a
sexual tyrannosaurus
i mean read it am i making this up
sexual trauma holy [ __ ] you know that
was a storyline in sex in the city
remember when we were visiting our
friend at the brewery we were walking
around and there was like that couple
[ __ ] in a container home
explain so at the brewery at the brewery
which is an artist colony in here
downtown l.a and the back part of it
there's like these container home
looking things they're really artsy oh i
know which one you're talking about i
remember us like walking in the back and
you just showing us like how cool that
is and they just hear
we're like oh it's really cool here it's
pretty cool
this place is cool it is an artist
colony a lot of art being made
so one complaint was listen i'm a
christian woman please help this girl
stop having loud sex before god does
no there's not even me another one
christians have some of the loudest sex
though oh bro
so much repression it's no more it's not
sinful anymore when they're married so
they're like finally unleashing unleash
the beast dude the mirens do that too
the mermans
that's why they get so many children do
they just get sex calls all the time
because they just live on top of each
other so just everyone is just maybe the
buildings are so old the walls are just
mad things
dude dudes don't get any nights off bro
they're just [ __ ] confident they're
drained huh
valentine's day those guys have heart
attacks and die most of the time that's
an observed mormon holiday yeah yeah
it's the most deaths on how did they
make their rounds you gotta lock those
[ __ ] up do the girls fight over who
gets first yeah there's a pecking order
probably yeah there's a pregnancy do
they all get along too they all know i
don't know but they act like this you
gotta watch the reality tv shows of
mermaids we watch them the mermaids are
[ __ ] fascinating yeah everyone goes
ooh i'd have five wives yeah and i'm
like no you don't want that i thought
that wasn't legal anymore in utah it is
because all the sounds all of you taught
the entire state yeah holy [ __ ]
weird
especially if you're [ __ ] in the
caves
which is where some of these people live
yeah they have sick homes so orgy going
on in the backyard boobs and penises
being flashed in the street that was
another call 3-1-1 i thought wow bear
boobs are legal in new york city only at
certain temperatures that's why they
call it 3-1-1
just kidding i don't know yeah it's a
complaint hotline nobody really can do
anything so what happens when you go
through who responds just like who shows
up uh underpaid people the old rock band
311 wow
that's the ringtone
hello
energy the most common complaint is the
volume at which many of their neighbors
are having sex one brooklyn resident
told 31 that the loudness kept him up
and he lost his job due to over sleeping
while a person in in queens said their
neighbor was quote shouting loudly that
he is a sexual tyrannosaurus
i'm a sexual tyrannosaurus you don't get
any better of a response by saying it's
sex noises right if something's just a
loud noise yeah it does a priority go up
if you can say a specific type of noise
like there's gunshots or something
or maybe they know that it's an
individual now like oh it's personal
room 13 versus gunshots could be
anywhere around the vicinity maybe so
they go like hopefully send someone to
room 13 album then wouldn't you also
think that like it's like oh it's like
this person's having crazy sex noises
maybe by the time somebody actually goes
out there to investigate it's like the
sex is done i feel like that's like
that's almost not as bad like when you
say it's sex and the [ __ ] mystery
solved the cops gonna take their time or
whoever comes here because just people
[ __ ] just give it a minute or two but
if you're like i don't know what's going
on up there like when i when i lived in
little toga i lived underneath this
asian couple and i swear to god one
night he was beating the [ __ ] out of her
oh and she was like screaming for her
life and you can just hear him
pounding her and i was like my whole
floor was getting out of their units and
they were like
do you think that's what it sounds like
and then everybody called the cops and
[ __ ] and they took their [ __ ] sweet
time you know by the time um they got
over there he opened the door and just
said no it's fine and then the cops were
like okay
later really didn't go let's see the
ladies 100 exactly but i am directly
below him and i could hear her every
word and everything has happened i'm
like dude no he was beating the [ __ ] out
of her the cops like no he said it's
fine so it's fine
dude my friend holy [ __ ] man she she
lives her and her boyfriend live in
burbank
and they heard like
screaming
like a girl like screaming for [ __ ]
bloody murder
she grabs a baseball bat her and her
boyfriend they run up to her room and
they're knocking into her hello hello
are you okay fine they come to find out
that she was filming a self tape
the audition yeah and then and then she
posted this video and it went like viral
on tick tock that's insane and she was
like oh my god i thought you were going
to [ __ ] die bro like keep it down
wow and it became viral that was crazy i
did not sleep well last night because
i'm staying at a hotel because i'm
hanging out with you guys because i live
in vegas now i appreciate you and i'm
not kidding but through the walls i
heard
uh and that guy is a sexual [ __ ] he's
like i'm a tyrannosaurus sex that's what
you sound like
i wish wow i'm very quiet you got you
guys like to talk loud during sex
like do you like that it's good yeah
it's good huh it's good you want to feel
that yeah i like answering the question
i like i like asking the question
no you like asking rhetorical questions
if a tree falls in the woods
is that what you like i like it
who's the [ __ ] is this one who's yours
yeah it's mine i don't wait for the
yours oh you just say yourself it's my
[ __ ]
joe's like joe's like say my name jill i
said it first
[ __ ]
yeah i'm not a big uh talker during love
not a lot of dialogue huh what are you
what are you are you a big breather what
do you do
you cry
i'm a mouth breather so i go
and i have to drink water in between
[ __ ] with the camel back on do you talk
about that
you talk about nutrition
[Laughter]
or you count the reps and sets yeah yeah
yeah take a break time time more set
hold on two minutes burning so many
calories right now i'm gonna end up at a
deficit but no just give me five more
minutes girl today is a [ __ ]
endurance day we doing five by five
that's right let's get ready now let's
get ready now i have a stop watch around
my wrist push through yeah that's never
happened to you by accident no
no [ __ ] got a [ __ ] janet jackson mic
and [ __ ] where the headphones go and one
and two and three
if i saw nick in one of those peloton
commercials where he's like biking in a
desert i'd [ __ ] love life i don't
think i could ever do that type of [ __ ]
really why like peloton that's all right
guys let's go come on like nah i'm not
i'm not really interested that sounded
really good that's your natural voice
dude no dude yeah have you seen me teach
a class that's exactly what you sound
like i talk like you guys all right
warm-ups everybody
all right guys let's go since you have
so much like martial arts habits like in
your body by that accident have you ever
countered like a passionate movement
with an attack sometimes well not like
that but i think sometimes tiff is like
she's like suck man
she likes to like grab me sometimes and
like tickle me and [ __ ] but i do get
really worried that i might like flinch
and there's been times where i have like
yo with the f and it was and i'm like
sorry you [ __ ] knock her off the
[ __ ] couch dude uh
no but i have to restrain her sometimes
because i'm like yo because i'm really
ticklish i get really ticklish to the
point where i'm like i will [ __ ] you
got natural jujitsu like you would like
underhook and [ __ ] yeah bro i tell her
that all the time like can you tickle
him with
is also mostly naked right now yeah i'm
dude i keep getting hot and then cold
if only your past opponents knew that
was your weakness back when you were
doing tournaments and [ __ ] but they all
knocked him out anyways
and then tickled his cold body
hey this guy's not ticklish
he's also not breathing
i still might laugh a little bit down
there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you